hey welcome to the Reuben report I'm the
comedic Leif furloughed Dave Rubin and
I've got bree essrig and ben mankiewicz
with me and before we start I do we do
have to address what has happened here
today in case we have some frenetic
energy on the show I was on the way here
stopped at McDonald's and I learned a
lesson never go to McDonald's dropped an
entire large coke from the drive-through
woman she just basically dumped it in my
lap I'm wearing backup pants then we get
here and what has been do spill my
entire full cup of coffee on my iPad but
my top like quick decision we have the I
have the wrist rapidity of an 18 year
old and I was able to snag my iPad it
appears safely out of the way and only
ruined my pants in my notebook see
people excessive masturbation
occasionally can work out for you okay
we're gonna get right to it and
hopefully not spill you don't have
anything to spill even know but I know
about that masturbation thing all right
so have you heard about this government
shutdown yeah they are shutdown I think
we're in day ten right now and you know
sure the NIH is closed so the kids can't
get cancer trials the world war ii
memorial is closed so veterans can't
even check that our parks are closed
800,000 people are furloughed die death
benefits for servicemen killed in the
line of duty the $20,000 they get to pay
for their funeral and help the family
with costs yeah not being issued not
being issued all kinds of craziness of
course though Congress there they're
still getting paid even though they're
the ones that got us into this because
you know they really deserve that but
not only are they getting paid their Jim
Congress is exclusive Jim that's also
considered essential and it's staying
open what do they have in there Jim well
they've got a swimming pool basketball
courts paddle ball courts a sauna steam
room flat-screen TVs but we should note
that the towel service has been
suspended I'm not making that up should
we expect any better from these people
they got us into this mess they furlough
all these people all these people are
getting screwed by this it's harming the
economy
their gym it's essential they do play
paddle ball some no so off the badges
yes horrible people it's like the worst
sport ever yeah is paddle paddle balls
elitist right paddle ball is I was about
to say do you use your hands but I'm
gonna catch you right there in the title
little blue ball a mouse yeah you're
talking about a group of men who
perennial e have blue balls yeah I
imagine yeah I don't know this is one of
those stories that like is so ripe who
thinks their gyms should be open right I
mean but it does tend to deflect from
the real issues you know it's just one
of those of course where you just get to
get mad at Congress all over again but
the real things you should be mad at
them for is you know irresponsible
governing a lack of interest in
government a hatred of government which
means of course if you hate government
when you shut down the thing you hate
they think it's good right there that's
why the you know just reading these
interviews today with some members of
Republican members of Congress
they're like impervious to the criticism
because they think the critics just
don't get it right so every time the
critics say to them well you know are
you willing to give up your pay or
should the gym be closed well that's not
what this is about
but so is this is just their way of like
extra sticking it to us sort of like
they're already sticking it to us and
it's very clear they're not doing the
work of the people they're not even
doing work so it's sort of like yeah
we're gonna keep our gym open too
because we are in charge
yeah it might be a good thing though
like exercise is really good for your
heart and we're just so stressed out
like they might have a heart attack so
yeah we start working out yeah and
legislating is all about ABS right
that's right you know the vice pres the
United States we are the fight the near
vice president United States last year
was sending out pictures with his
baseball cap on backwards and leering at
the elbow I believe he was on he was
doing the p90x wasn't he right so that I
don't know that that's having you seen
that commercial you get some straps oh
that's what yeah so that you can do in
the privacy wall you don't even need a
gym for it that's the woman but what we
forget is these guys met especially
members of the tea party but some other
members of Congress to a lot of these
guys live in their office because they
think that they're in the people's house
and they're doing the people's work and
they don't want to be part of the
Washington establishment so they go up
briefed
to Washington for the least amount of
time possible save money they always say
but it's not really saving the people's
money they're just they're just saving
their money right there electric bill
they're not doing the people's work
you're just a cheap
yeah perhaps you need to realize that
yeah and so these guys stay there so
they use the gym as their shower because
there are no showers in members offices
so like now though what that essentially
means is that these guys who live in
their offices are just you know banging
their secretaries on the people's futon
you know see I was gonna say I feel like
they're all in the shower together
could be that would be better well a lot
of the Republicans because you know they
like they'll kind of stuff yeah yeah so
if we can't expect better then we just
have to where do you think this thing is
going at this point because if they just
keep pulling all this stuff I mean again
I totally agree with you that it's it's
all a distraction the World War Two
memorial think it's a distraction from
the real stuff but with all this stuff
for some reason this hits people harder
right when you hear about the World War
Two memorial thing you hear about the
gym being open it's more of a visceral
feeling because people are out of work
and they're not even giving up a perk
right exact you know exactly so it's bad
I would have closed it also I mean if
you noticed you read the story the
decision to close the gym was made by
the capital architect
yes very you would imagine that this
guy's work was done it was finished
you'd be like hey Larry great dome
thanks for your work but no they call
Larry back and he's like keep the gym
open yeah how is it is he but he made it
in conjunction with the speaker's office
and they so they went along with it and
I'm gonna guess that Speaker Boehner he
reached those stories he sees
congressional job approvals at 9% and
he's like well I can't go any lower yeah
I'll just keep the gym open yeah so I
eight people came out today the
Congress's approval is now at 5% so it
can't go yeah we can go slightly lower
is there any what other people could
there be besides Congress that could be
so bad at their job is there anyone else
if all bus drivers were this bad we'd
find another mode of transportation
wouldn't we I don't think so you think
we'd still take the baby great I'll take
the bus you're right nobody's taking the
bus out of joy it's always it's always
been true is that guys think they hate
Congress but they like their
congressman and so you know it's always
been like Congress is the worst it's
terrible my guy he's good I like him I'd
like to begin I'd like him a hundred
times yeah he hates black people eat
gays of pretty journey H Jews he can't
say that
I don't have to and so you know you
always send your guy back and of course
that just means 435 guys basically go
back doing a lot of nothing all right
well speaking of the gays we actually
have some good gay news the Dean of the
Washington National Cathedral his name
is Gary Hall He is calling homophobia a
sin not homosexuality homophobia a sin
in a sermon on Sunday he said this
homophobia is a sin heterosexism is a
sin shaming people for who they love is
a sin shaming people because their
gender identity doesn't fit neatly into
your sense of what it should be is a sin
only when all churches say that clearly
and boldly and courageously will our
LGBT youth be free to grow up in a
culture that totally embraces them fully
as they are I mean obviously for me this
this seems pretty great and I think we
have to give some props to to the Pope
he seems to be turning things around in
in the religious day spear is that a
that's a club I think this is all good
right means any do we have any negative
thing attached to this whatsoever pretty
great no you could be cynical I suppose
uh you know and suggest that he's
looking out on Sundays at the flock
these are this is the National Cathedral
so these are his companions yeah and
looking out there and saying you know
where of all the twenty and thirty year
olds gone they're tired of the gay hate
but I think you're right Dave I think
it's I think the Pope sort of opened
things up and the very Reverend the very
yeah so can you explain what they're
very is good Thursday calling here is a
very very revered he's just super
Reverend extra yeah everything he does
is Reverend he's very Reverend II yes no
it's a I get term given by the a lot of
religions use that the Episcopal 's
Episcopalians give it to just senior
priests so right he's an important dude
and a very important dude and I think he
heard the Pope and I think he thought I
don't want to be left off this he
we thought it for years but you can't
say it or you risk the death of your own
career
of course the Episcopalians here have
been split for a long time because they
they made Gene Robinson I think was his
name in Connecticut a bishop was openly
gay for which caused this huge split
between conservative Episcopalians and
and and more forward-thinking people so
but I think he heard the Pope and he
thought I don't want to be left out this
is the Pope even though it's a different
religion has opened up a window where I
think I can say this yeah now the Pope
obviously he's Roman Catholic so he
doesn't directly affect the
Episcopalians but it's all sort of you
know sort of fits like we don't want it
all of a sudden like one thing
Episcopalians had it's maybe we're maybe
we're not as conservative as the
Catholics now like hold on yeah exactly
what can we do to give the pope and and
the very Reverend Gary Hall what can we
do to give them props because I think
for the LGBT community if you don't step
up and acknowledge when things are
actually changing then they won't change
exactly this is so wonderful
especially when you have like these
leaders that people look up to and they
and they really get all their knowledge
almost from these people yeah I'm
certainly not the Bible because I don't
know I
corstel yes so it's immense yeah sure I
think it's great I don't know how we get
props other than talking about it
tweeting about it retweeting the Pope I
know how one thing that you could
possibly do so how much further how much
further do we have to go here because if
if religion is finally coming around on
the gay thing and the Supreme Court's
made some decisions and things are
really happening here and really all
over the world
how much further till this is just
completely out of the public discourse
that let's deal with America first like
is there a chance that one of the GOP
guys in 2016 you think is gonna jump on
board cuz then because this is sort of
past but right I hope so because I feel
like I feel like most people are I feel
like most of these guys are but they
just change their political views to
match the people that are that they're
running for it and I feel like that's
just so stupid why can't we have like a
platform someone on a platform that
stands for everything like it stands for
the people what people a lot of people
yeah not the Congress that's not kind of
great we just had an election that was
essentially about like whether somebody
wanted responsible regular
and someone wanted a little bit more and
that we debated high tax rate of Lake
whether it should be 31 or 27 okay that
was an actual debate we had in this
country yeah but but you know yeah I
think in 2016 there's a possibility
because you're already looking at you
know you wonder whether is chris
Christie
you know he's Roman Catholic and maybe
he is chris christie not doesn't engage
in hostile anti-gay talk yeah i'm not a
hundred percent sure that it's not for
gay marriage but it's very bizarre in
jersey because it seems like the rest of
the state is and he is challenging the
New Jersey Supreme Court's decision
right but it is is engaging the rhetoric
I mean it might not be such a huge
stretch if like what the Pope said
influenced him and he said look I'm
against gay marriage but I this is but
it's 78th on my list of things that I
care about yeah you know I think it's me
because the fact I doesn't want to make
a jokes it's just it's too easy to make
that yeah I will say that anytime a
major religion sort of starts coming out
and lets somebody off the hook in this
to speak oddly of it but it says you
know what maybe we should ease up on the
gays that basically means that it's bad
for the Jews you got a place like hey
you know what we'll just go back to hate
the Jews yeah that always works
everybody loves that yeah so last last
other so what's that if keep the gays
get full equality then what's next and
then everything's normal and cool right
answer it for all the gays well I mean I
don't know I just wish that people would
separate this from politics and from
religion in general so hopefully it's
just it just becomes normal like it is
normal so why can't people just like let
it be normal I don't know 2012 I mean I
get nobody vote of course cuz he was the
same yeah yeah
Robo Trebek he used to stand up there at
the debates and be like I'm saying is
anyone paying attention cuz he was kinda
he was sort of decently
I mean kind of Pro gay and he's since
the election has come out even more so
okay let's move on so this story is just
completely bonkers
school officials at Weber middle school
in Long Island not too far from where I
grew up from they are basically banning
fun yeah at recess
the kids will no longer be able to play
with items such as footballs hard soccer
balls baseballs lacrosse balls or
anything that might hurt someone on
school grounds all these things are
banned from resets and this I love rough
games of tag or cartwheels unless
supervised by a coach so if you're being
supervised by the cartwheel coach I
guess you could do a cartwheel this
seems just profoundly awful to me kids
need to run around and do stupid things
and fall off trampolines and monkey bars
they need to exercise their bodies and
their brains because like what is going
on such you need to be able to
fake injuries so they can get out of
class which is what I did yeah
did you ever go to class you were
constantly everything because I can
dislocate my shoulder really so I did
that a lot but but it's so it really is
jokes aside it's the most important
thing because would you rather have your
kid outside playing with the chance he
gets hurt say he gets hurt breaks his
arm or her then she gets a really cool
cast and all the kids get to sign it and
she feels cool for a minute or would you
rather have them sitting on the computer
right during recess right so of course
what this is about is they don't want
them out there and they're you know
banging up their knees and they're
getting scrapes all things that have
happened throughout the course of time
I'm pretty sure then you're taking
recess away it's all horseshit it's all
liability it's it's school district
worried about lawyers worried about
getting sued and it's going to turn
every one of these kids into a
Republican that's like yeah you could
just I can smell it because you know you
like Matt Drudge reads this story right
the regulations the Democrats take it
away recess and in this case this is
regulation gone too far yeah like I mean
you're just you're overly involved here
in people's lives let the kids play
football obviously if they're tackling
each other on school property you go up
and you go hey you don't you got to play
touch yeah that's cool yeah it's not
complicated but also they're still gonna
be able to play football they just gotta
play it with a nerf football yeah so you
can still hurt someone you
hurt someone with a nerve oh yeah you
can right yeah one of those in the eye I
feel hurt totally yeah it's hard to get
that foam out of your eyes I watched the
story that this was a television story
that we were reading that we were
looking at him and they interviewed a
because you know the reporter has to
make an effort this is one of the
problems with the media is that they
can't do this story and go this is
obviously about liability right and this
is stupid right so they go and they
talked to somebody in the ER there and
they got and they asked him you know
what kind of injuries have you been
seeing at school and of course what he's
been seeing is the same injuries he's
always seen yeah knee goes well head
injuries bumps it's great yeah yeah
brain finger just bring it down
everything's fine yeah all right so
removing the legal part out of this for
a second because it's obviously about
the legal part why is it that they
always want to cut the things that are
important like if I was to look back on
childhood which was pretty pretty decent
I went to a pretty decent school system
like if they could have done anything
different I would say more recess if I
had a kid right now I'd want them to
take more music classes and more art
classes and not be zoning out like I did
during all the other classes but why do
we always go to the seemingly good
things it's just because we're a bunch
of liberal hippies here you liberal I
don't even know I maybe they just want
everyone to be like pale and not see
sunshine or something that's a good
aspect I lack the vitamin D for these
kids I remember years ago when I was
doing the show with Jack I was doing the
The Young Turks with Jack and there was
a story I'm pretty sure it was in Dallas
and at graduation they wouldn't allow
teachers faculty members whether it was
the principal or just a teacher during
graduation to hug a student like you
know you see your teacher who's like
been there for years and you're like you
know Larry way to go good luck to you
right they don't want it because of the
fear of the feelings of the un-- hugged
oh my goodness I swear to god that's a
quote in case this guy was playing
favorites basic right not yeah because
her laying favorites but like if he's
not gonna hug everyone you can
that rule right it's crazy well that's
the cupcake rule the third-grade cupcake
rule if it's your birthday you have to
bring it in cupcakes for everybody yeah
and and so you can't infer and then
there were schools that wouldn't allow
birthdays to happen any birthday
celebration at all because of the kids
who had birthdays in June July August
who didn't get to celebrate the
birthdays at school let me take the
unhooked kids in Dallas or okay great
point maybe this is like a case of I
don't know they're just defending the
Nerds and/or kids that aren't good at
sports and they're like well these kids
aren't good at sports oh no no one can
play sports ha ha ha yeah
but isn't that dangerous though like
even if you were to even prescribe that
to the to the bullying thing which
obviously there is a bullying problem in
middle schools and high schools or
whatever but that you get bullied in
real life too hastily you're gonna be
bullied far more in real life than as a
kid so if you take all of that out and
you take out the competitiveness and
learning how to be a team player in
kickball or whatever you take all that
out of childhood then you dump some kid
out into the real world and yeah you're
gonna get far more bullied than you were
before right absolutely I'm getting a
lot of head knives out of you so I thank
you I think you're on the crazy I think
you nailed that bullying we eliminate
bullying you don't eliminate everything
else and and again you got to be grades
of bullying but you know as soon as you
tell school administrators who are
there's some great people in school but
yeah running schools but when you start
to the school administration as soon as
you apply that zero-tolerance policy
then you're expelling kids for bringing
a plastic knife to peel their orange you
know and it's a zero tolerance is almost
never works unless it's like zero
tolerance for rape right you know I mean
I think we can write mostly right
minimal tolerance yeah yeah so I'm with
you it's a crazy story and it makes us
it makes the whole country look bad I
like a final thought I went to an arts
boarding school for my junior and senior
year of high school and our PE was hacky
sack because we played soccer once and
they had to cancel that because you
can't hurt the musicians because they
need their hands or play their musical
instruments so that's I mean with the
lack of sports physical activity look
what happened to me I'm super pale I
stay indoors a lot I'm kind of
anti-social
right
your early computer all the time but
what if you say I'm not losing any
apparently masturbate too much wrong
with you but Hagee said you could hurt
yourself with that he said twisted ankle
which then if your what's give me an
instrument that you might need your foot
for you know piano you give me a
thousand instruments to the user foot
for our piano would not have good
alright moving on so we did one good
story for the gays but in the gay world
those things you're a yin and yang and
here's a bad one for the gays so Kuwait
I can't believe this they have developed
some sort of futuristic incredible
gaydar that I thought only gay people
had that's right Yosef mind car sounds
like dr. Mindbender from GI Joe he is
the director of public health at the
Kuwaiti Health Ministry and he has he's
given us this new gaydar let's let's
take a look the quote health centers
conduct the routine medical check to
assess the health of expatriates when
they come back into the GCC countries
however we will take stricter measures
that will help us detect gays who will
then be barred from entering Kuwait or
any of the GCC Member States let's just
look at the GCC member states real quick
they are Bahrain Kuwait Oman Qatar or
Qatar depending on what day it is Saudi
Arabia and the United Arab Emirates so
these these are countries where
homosexual acts are banned we let's get
that list up one more time
also known as America's closest allies
in the Middle East really these are
these are all considered allies in the
United States and - maybe Oman Oman come
yeah sure yeah so those are pretty yeah
all right so we're lined up with these
guys they're doing gaydar tests before
we get into it any further what do you
think this gaydar test might entail god
I don't know lots of fingers I don't
know what they're gonna do but I hope my
brother doesn't have to go to Kuwait
because he's just straight as they come
but any gaydar test he's gonna fail yeah
this is a guy who gets a pedicure during
the Superbowl you can sure that's online
right and whatever they're doing they're
in Kuwait I'm sorry yeah I don't exactly
know what this is
but you can't come in right I mean even
whatever there I'm not sure of the
methodology of how they're going about
doing this but whatever it is because
this is so backwards it's going to be
things like that oh the guy has uh you
know nicely trimmed nails he's obviously
gay you get it some bear from West
Hollywood they're not gonna think he's
days a big fat we're making fun of it
right but it just invites every dumb
indirect stereotype about gay people
yeah what about straight what does it
say about the way we choose our allies
in the United States because as you said
all these are United States ally
countries and I get obviously every
country is different and everybody's
gonna have different laws we don't even
have gay marriage here to the last
couple months so fine
but shouldn't we have like a tiered
system of like you gotta have some basic
human rights to be our prime time allies
Saudi Arabia we're pretty close to them
you know women can't vote there they
can't drive supposedly they're gonna be
able to vote in a couple years but they
might be able to drive together all
these days they can vote for like dog
catcher like it's super low municipal
elections yeah exactly
so shouldn't we doesn't that have
anything to do with how we pick our
allies that we should have just like a
basic set of standards like you got to
treat your women equally before we
should it should be that way but it's
more like what can they offer us what
they have over there that might start
with a no I don't know I or new year old
yeah so of course and obviously in a you
know region that includes you know the
Taliban and al Qaeda in you know in in
various elements in in Yemen and
Pakistan and Afghanistan and other
places as well obviously you know so
many of the 19 hijackers and on
September 11th came from Saudi Arabia
like it's freaking complicated you know
and so what are you supposed to do
I mean what's interesting though is that
if they had a test to determine in those
countries whether these people were
Jewish now that then we might actually
do something you know so but you know
that could be similar
because of the circumcision so there's
something it's something about the penis
oh that's right you know well dress so
is it a boy yeah it's a you know look
anytime you sort of break down I mean
look everybody wants us to be allies
with China and Russia that makes sense
but I mean but they don't have great
they have terrible human rights records
they have shameful human rights records
but it's better to be friends with
people and I think it's better to
influence change from within unless
they're doing something particularly
hideous like North Korea or in the minds
of some you know Iran yeah do you think
they ever realize how much they're
losing by not integrating gay people
like if you think of all the great
things all the great art and music and
almost every the clothes and everything
that usually comes from gay people and
they don't have any of that it's a damn
shame is the music of Kuwaitis taken a
major yeah Kuwaiti music would be like
the most important being the world if
there's just a couple of gay expats back
in the country
you let like a gay One Direction a
Kuwaiti one direction I mean my god baby
you wanted to well they say that one of
them yeah we'll discuss this off yeah
there was one part of the story that was
great because Bahrain which was on that
list weren't they yes yet arrested 127
people in 2011 for holding and this is a
quote from Gulf News yes for holding a
depraved and decadent party which for
the first time made me want to go to
Bahrain because what do you think that
and what does that encompass it's to
pray me whatever they're people having
sex and dark corners and you're having
sex with strangers gay straight don't
care I want to internet party a party
for me 98% of the time it's like me in
the corner next to no one drinking a
sprite zero scanned in the room for a
television to watch the game that I
would be watching if I'd stay at home
and was enjoying myself I think he would
enjoy yourself a lot more if you just
had regular spray
sprite it just sounded a zero it's like
nothing you're drinking nothing actually
it was great as when I wrote that light
I had sprite and then and then I crossed
it out I was like sprite cereal in here
see people and then it get like you come
back with it look the funniest line of
all it's perfect we taught you a little
salad a little something about human
rights and a little something about
comedy in that segment there you go all
right let's move on let's talk politics
for a second so we started with this a
little bit earlier but it seems to me
that everything with the shutdown and
Obamacare and the debt ceiling and all
this nonsense is about 2016 and it's
it's all the GOP guys jockeying for
position and I hate sort of talking
about this stuff too much because it's
years from now and then it stops us from
dealing with things that we should be
talking about now
however Howard Fineman wrote a really
good piece in HuffPost that talked about
how they're all just angling themselves
to become the nominee in 2016 and how
that's gonna work through the primary
process and all that and you know he
talked obviously about Ted Cruz who's
become like the hero of the Tea Party
which started with his 21 hour
filibuster that wasn't really a
filibuster Rand Paul gets the
libertarian wing Marco Rubio you know he
had that immigration bill that was sort
of DOA Paul Ryan's obviously gonna be in
the mix because of his PDX 90 abs and
then and then chris Christie of course
who's not in Congress right now so he
may be the winner here
because he doesn't even have to get in
the fray of this whole big mess so again
I don't really like getting into this
stuff but we sort of got to talk about
it because it gives context to why
everything's so broken because three
years before the election these guys are
doing things to position themselves so
if we ignore it it's still it's still
happening right yeah I may not know a
lot about politics but I know a lot
about being broken yeah so as a broke as
a broken person are you constantly using
things for years later to to manipulate
the future as they are trying to fix
myself I try I tried it I take a lot of
advice from people yeah I never go about
it on my own that's for sure yeah so Ted
Cruz wouldn't like you because he's a
rebel he's a loner yeah but you like
teammate I do I like to work work
together yeah love and peace guys Ben
what do you think I think that
I'm with you that I the the mainstream
media makes an enormous mistake and and
does a disservice to covering important
issues when they cover everything in a
horse race doesn't matter what you say
it only matters what you say and how it
relates and I engage in it I love it I
love the race but I think right but not
at the but it shouldn't come at the
expense of talking about like how these
people would govern and what that would
mean yeah the difference here is that in
order to cover accurately what's
happening in Washington now you have to
cover this part of it because everything
these guys are doing has nothing to do
with what they accomplished now since
all of them actually acknowledge we
can't defund Obamacare and eventually
we're going to start the government back
up we have to pay everybody back right
well okay sure everyone's saying that
except for Ted Cruz I feel like he still
thinks he can not fund it and win this I
don't but either way I said I can't peer
into the soul of a crazy person yeah
right but what he mostly wants was to be
front and center right and the voice of
this sort of radical I hate government I
hate the people who run government I
hate the things the government does yeah
and he worked you know he's at 20%
they're all like all the guys you
mentioned are between 10 and 20 percent
in the latest polls but Ted Cruz is a
guy he got elected to the Senate like
Wednesday and now all of a sudden in a
straw poll he actually leads among
Republicans that's what he wanted so you
have to talk about it yeah it's part of
the problem here that also that somehow
this stuff is juicier because these guys
are all such characters I feel like
they're all cartoon characters Rand
Paul's hair the size of Chris Christie
like they're all sort of cartoon
characters and that's more exciting than
talking about like the minutiae of a
bill isn't it like you can just make fun
of them and that keeps it in the
discussion it makes it fun for people
that aren't really interested in
politics right but we can live tweet
speeches and events and it's fun for
everyone
yeah is that I mean I do it all the time
no that's fun I do too yeah I have no
idea what I'm talking about I just like
to tweet so it's super fun but it is a
problem yeah is that part of the problem
that because the policy stuff is just
not the stuff that gets people talking
we could be sitting here at breaking
down some policy and we'd get sick
speeds
they they take advantage of the fact
that that and the press too and they're
a lot obviously you know your show Dave
and when we do the Young Turks and all
these shows are dependent on good
reporters doing their jobs you have
information to talk about so they're
great reporters out there but as a whole
they don't take a lot of time explaining
stuff because they don't really know and
it's hard to get at I mean the the
Affordable Care Act is confusing yeah
right and it's difficult and of course
reporting on what's wrong with the
Affordable Care Act now it's pointless
we don't know what's wrong with it or
what's right with it
it's a giant huge bill and it needs a
year yeah to breathe and then obviously
like Social Security and you go in and
you fix the problems but that requires
it but no there's a glitch so we have to
shuck out the whole thing and that
doesn't there's nothing about what I
just said that works in a 24-hour news
cycle let alone forget 24 hours a four
hour news cycle yeah on cable and the
internet it's just so this and these
guys know that so they make a big speech
they make a big Proclamation they make
sort of definitive points the press
covers it and they get their way yeah
well you know we talk about this all the
time here about how the mainstream media
is so untrustworthy I was watching Fox
News the other day and they were like
you know look at the system the Obama
care system the computers are crashing
because it's so inept and glitchy and
bla bla bla literally turned to MSNBC
they're showing the same screen of the
glitches and they're saying it's because
too many people were on there so it's
over you know because it's too good
so it's overloading the service and it's
like I'm pretty sure you're both lying I
don't know what's going on on CNN
they're just showing Anderson's hair for
like you know actually it's like who
knows what's wrong you know again of
course I come at it with bias but I'm
pretty sure it's a lot closer to the
MSNBC thing because when you offer
people the chance to tell them they're
gonna think yeah I'll do that
especially every single one of those
people as a child yeah and they'll think
the first day what I'm gonna do my
sign-off I'm gonna make sure that my
family has health care yeah so I would
you know there you heard it been trusty
MSNBC slightly more than he trusts Fox
News all right here we go this is a
great story is our last story so
Switzerland has a bill pending that is
going to give every adult in the country
twenty eight hundred bucks a month
they are gonna vote on this shortly and
they want a basic minimum sort of living
standard for everybody and I just saw
this and I think this is kind of great
now they're a very small country far
smaller than America just to give you
some perspective their population is 7.9
million people
it's basically like New York New York
has 8.3 million what do we have you're
like 300 million so it's not we can't
really compare this through you know
through the American lens because
obviously they're much smaller and they
can do things on a micro level that we
could never do here I think though of
the 300 million in America I think 180
million of them are Mexicans taking our
job that's what I hear it's just people
on the la freeways yeah yeah exactly
so all right so basically Switzerland
which already has universal health care
by the way which is given to everybody
and if you're rich you do pay a little
bit of a higher premium again seems like
a pretty fair system so they seem to be
doing something good there is there
anything that we as Americans can take
away from this system that's trying to
give people just sort of like a baseline
to be like okay you can live and then go
from there is there anything we can gain
from that from a system like that uh yes
I would like that $2,800 one if you
could buy so much hot chocolate with
that that would be a tremendous mi from
Switzerland that Swiss Miss everybody
you know like the actual everybody would
get a Swiss Army knife that would be
good that would be great one more one
more super convenient of course ja I
mean oh my god so look they have
happiness fun day of happiness because
they're all equal look we have the best
system of everything in this country our
country is the best and we can't learn
anything from anyone ever yeah I don't
know what kind of question you I don't
know what kind of America cating slant
you take it when you probably learned
something with Switzerland no yeah
and their dogs and their cheese and
their stupid hot chocolate in the
packets and the scheme incredibly hot
women and yeah sex with strangers I
don't know that happens but I sense that
that's part of its like you know you say
it's a small cookie but it's eight
million people it's not Italy's right
like I mean they got they
country and you know and they of course
have strict immigration laws themselves
because otherwise if they do this you
would imagine that some neighbors in
Germany and France who might be less
well-off would think well let's go to
Switzerland and get the 34800 oh yeah I
would just say it'd be nice to feel
comfortable month-to-month that just
that alone just that that fact that'd be
nice that would be nice do things like
this ever make you think that the United
States actually is too big to function
because even if you look at everything
going on in Congress right now that our
lives say here in California with
obviously a more liberal set of beliefs
than say a congressman in you know
Arkansas or something that this guy is
still voting on the things that affect
our lives when we really live its
seemingly in another part of the world
altogether it's kind of crazy yeah it
feels like that yeah now missus session
is to or something like I you know look
I states rights don't interest me and
the I mean I would I would have so many
more federal laws really yeah I don't
think it's because I don't think states
know what they're doing we've sort of
had this that we presuppose that the
states all make the right decisions
California has made a series of horrible
decisions of course we have this
incredibly silly system of the
referendums yeah we're uneducated people
myself included right I go to the polls
and I'm like issue seven a you know
right well isn't that like prop eight
the great example of that because I was
like people still weren't sure whether
they left the booth I voted YES on Prop
eight does that mean I'm for gay
marriage or against gay marriage I think
it meant you were yeah against if you
voted yes there was a lot of compelling
information that if the vote had been
for gay marriage or against gay marriage
that for gay marriage were two one yeah
right so it's a silly way of doing
things and and and I don't think that
because you can do something in one
state that it seems silly to me that you
can't do it in another state yeah so
getting back to Switzerland for a second
do you think all these people are just
gonna stop working once you have like
just if you just had the basic amount of
money and could pretty much pay your
rent and live would you just retire with
the bree essrig operation over or would
just beginning no wait we just began i i
would feel comfortable and i would be
able to do the job that i want to do
yeah i think that's the most important
thing you can actually do spend your
doing what you want to do yeah do you
think there is some risk I guess it's
very anti capitalism the idea that you'd
be given something even if it just puts
you at a baseline the capitalism people
the capitalism doesn't work so people
can make thirty four thousand eight
hundred seven with that the math you
know I'm right it's two hundred off
twelve oh so it's a it's twenty four
hundred less than thirty six thousand so
it's uh so it's a thirty three six
appreciate apologize thirty-three six a
year so no of course it's not going to
stop the desire of people to get ahead
will it stop some people yeah yeah and
like you know there's that guy that you
know FoxNews jumped on a couple of weeks
ago that kid in in in here in Los
Angeles either in Manhattan Beach or
maybe using Malibu but he was taking
government assistance right right and
spending all his money just eatin pizza
and surfing surfing because that's what
he wanted to do and Fox is like aha this
is what the people on the government
okay you found it but but you know what
they're here the rest of them the
millions of others what they do is they
buy their food yeah so there you go I'll
say this one right to the camera not all
poor people are surfers in case you
don't watch Bill O'Reilly
all right I want to thank Ben mankiewicz
bree essrig their twitters are right
below them oh and I want to remind you
that our pet partner that's right we've
got a pet partner people is Koopa
dot-com live up to 75% off pet shoes and
toys all kinds of fun stuff and if you
use code RR you get another 20% off the
link is right down below yes Ben I did
it today you did it today I ordered
something I put in our arm I got 20%
more oh my good god now you're a dog guy
three dogs if I'm not mistaken that's
right that's two dogs you're not and I
have one dog that's a lot of dog hair on
us in places you can't see right now all
right
oh and don't forget to subscribe it's
right down there thank you and we'll do
it again next week okay